nobody you're cute What's it feel like
after 11 years do you still like IOI's
one well I think you know I I think that
everything you know relationships I be
this cliche but you have to kind of
[ __ ] stay in there it takes a lot of
courage to really stay with someone and
to really like go through [ __ ] I mean
there's not any couple that stays
together you have to go through you know
stuff together and have to be willing to
go through that and you know it's like
it's like a commitment it's a commitment
to growth really you know things that
you to grow or die you know and I think
relationships go through that you know
sometimes they go they go fallow and and
so and then you gotta make you know kind
of recommit it's not easy I mean anybody
will tell you that who's been together
for a while how long you guys been two
years the longest relationship I've ever
had is that right yeah yeah this is by
far the longest one for you yeah we've
ever before or no what I was never
married
yeah so you were well you must have been
your love I mean that's love
what's that were you in love take it
easy I mean I've said you know I'm gonna
buy a ring in yeah do you feel as though
sometimes when it's such a well-oiled
machine we're we're in our fourth year
now were things we don't when you've
been together you've you understand each
other's boundaries everything seems to
kind of move along you know well and
easily right it becomes at least for us
you sort of lose a little bit of the
romance because it is so efficient it's
true and I sometimes think that when
there's more romance when there's a
little bit more chaos more I know about
chaos I don't know if chaos is the word
or a little bit more romance when
there's more uncertainty yeah I don't
know I I think that when things are
going good and
they're smooth you know that you know
you just have to kind of make an effort
to put the romance in yeah you know what
I mean
oh yeah yeah you could do yeah
well it's it's hard because we have
these animals in space just watching you
the whole time you know oh really we try
to [ __ ] last week with the dog in the
room baklava it was impossible yeah she
barked she tries to protect me so she's
very true yeah she blocks my body she
doesn't want him no way oh so it's your
dog
well no she just want physical - you
have to be you know you have to also
take take the dog into your life more I
think the dog doesn't block yeah like
the dog is sensing something yeah you
know I should be friendly the dog [ __ ]
fart I didn't say because I do Eddie
[Laughter]
that may be why the dog is blocking you
[Music]